the second largest movie theater chain
in the u.s is temporarily
closing its doors again affecting some
40 000 workers
regal's parent company announced this
morning it will shut down its 536
theaters in america
indefinitely starting on thursday regal
had reopened some locations in august
after closing for at least five months
during the pandemic
postponed movies include sadly the
latest james bond epic no time to die
they're pulling key revenue from the
struggling industry theaters
we're hoping the double 07 movie would
sell more tickets but it was just
delayed
again until next april this has been a
real blow to the movie industry at least
40 000 people
are in danger of losing their jobs one
executive said we're like a grocery shop
that doesn't have vegetables fruit or
meat
basically nothing to sell yeah they were
suspecting that the latest christopher
nolan film tenet would revitalize some
of those prospects
sadly it's done well in countries abroad
where they followed the rules
and got rid of the pandemic at least as
best as they could but not here although
i just had an idea about food in the
theater if they had take away popcorn i
would go for some theater popcorn i had
had in so long
just a thought